good morning believe nation today's
message is don't get comfortable over to
you jack welch
I wake up every morning when espresso TV
go if you're sitting there comfortable
in what you're doing you can be sure
with you with your nicer Ward's of
number one here number one here number
one the booze a gap and number one this
one number one that one somebody's out
there waiting to pluck you and you can't
get comfortable and a bad rate of change
if you start seeing stuff you gotta move
so what do you think I love this I think
it's really great to always challenge
yourself and like for example I love to
take dance classes and I like to take
new dance classes the challenge one
where I'm at and not just do the ones
that are comfortable i love to do those
two because they're fun but i also want
to do ones that are really hard and
sometimes i go to end class feeling look
like i sucked but it's good because i
challenged myself right so don't get
comfortable keep improving yourself yeah
i think i think it's human beings we
like learning we like growth and the
minute you stop learning and stop
growing as a person you you lose
happiness and i think it happens to a
lot of entrepreneurs it's super common
once you've gotten started in business
and then at the start you're all excited
you got tons of ideas maybe bringing on
some customers and then at some point
you just fall into the pattern of doing
the same thing over and over and over
and over again and you gotten
comfortable and it gets boring and you
need to continue to challenge yourself
to do something new and exciting and
scary and I know it's especially hard I
think for entrepreneurs because we don't
have a boss because nobody pushing us to
go say hey I believe when you are
thinking you'll be a public speaker I
think you can go create this new product
you're pushing yourself and when you do
that you tend not to push yourself as
far right as somebody else could push
you and so I think that holds a lot of
entrepreneurs back where you do we do
what we're comfortable with we do what
we know and then we just fall into this
habit for the rest of our lives where
you want to make sure you have resources
people ideas that shake you out of your
comfort zone out of your habit to do
something a little bit scary every now
and then
I agree good things you would tell your
friends to do if you until your friends
to try something new and you should do
it too I like I like a good advice so
the question of the day today is what
was the last time you tried something
new no is yourself and what was it I'm
curious leave it in the comments below
we're going to join a discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day UT to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shut
up in Fresno expresso give me